What does the term ige refer to?
Non-binary people?
In other words,
they are neither a man nor a woman,
they are not non-binary people,
is it clear to you yet?
the fluid gender they are talking about?
They are non-binary persons and have every right to
to exist,
to have its existence recognized
even if it is rare or difficult to understand.
There are many things that may seem strange to us
or difficult to understand.
But one thing is that it's weird for us,
difficult to understand and that we have to open a book,
or talking to a non-binary person
to try to understand their situation,
discrimination faced by the
for being a non-binary person
and another one than me,
especially as Minister of the Government of Spain
and particularly as Minister of Equality,
which therefore falls within my competence.
Hey this question
do not send them a strong message.
And I know they exist,
even if there is social ignorance
about what their reality is,
and I recognize my obligation to them
to guarantee their rights.
And the first right is the right to exist